now you guys may remember
back in june i had some masked fun with
my buddy crash bandicoot announcing
crash 4 it's about time
with the game coming in october crash of
course had to come back for opening
night live so let's bring him out
everybody crash bandicoot
what he's where
[Music]
[Music]
poor crash apparently didn't get the
memo about gamescom but to tell us more
about what we just saw i'm joined
by lou studdard from toys for bob uh lou
what did we see there with the crash in
the games combat
uh apparently you saw him wandering
around cologne but uh what he was
hinting at
was kind of our reveal of what we call
flashback tapes which are a brand new
style of level that we are announcing
here today
okay so uh how do these flashback levels
kind of play into the overall crash for
narrative
yeah so the way that the the flashback
tape levels work is that
they are kind of a peak back in time to
the 90s
when neocortex was actually testing on
crash and coco
before the events of crash bandicoot 1.
and they're kind of these
devious puzzle rooms that we've made
and they're really hard and they're
really awesome
and they're super creative and we can't
wait to get people's hands on them
yeah no i i got to play a demo of this a
few weeks ago and that was a challenge
so i can't imagine
um how nefarious these are um how are
they going to be sort of integrated into
the game are they
they optional like offshoot stuff or how
do you get to them
sure so players actually have to collect
the flashback tapes
in the levels themselves uh they're an
object that they can pick up
and to actually pick them up they have
to reach them in the level without dying
it's kind of our homage to the death
routes from the original trilogy so
players have to
reach these objects in the level pick
them up and then once they get them
they'll get access to these
unique levels so beyond the pure
challenge
uh what other funds how are these fun
for players
to kind of experience what do they get
to do on them
sure so one of the things that we did
was we actually used these as
like i said puzzle rooms really kind of
fun nefarious devious ways for
crash to really express that pure
platforming
kind of uh aspect of gameplay that we
know and love about the franchise but
then
narratively for us it was really cool to
layer in
kind of a unique perspective to the
franchise this is the moment when
cortex is really excited about the
prospect of
crash being on his team because crash
was originally
created by cortex and so this is a weird
point in time that's never really been
explored in the games before
awesome all right well crash 4 it's
about time looks
phenomenal lou we cannot wait to check
it out
in october thanks for joining us yeah
thanks for having me
awesome all right well we will be right
back after this
for more gamescom opening night live